what you're about to watch is a clip
from my brand lytics training where i
get together with entrepreneurs thought
leaders who want to build their brand
using youtube and making data driven
decisions to blow up their brand this
year enjoy
series analytics this is where
when you have some kind of consistent
content you can start to look at what
kinds of videos are performing well
versus not
so
serious examples could be you're going
to do a talking head video you're going
to do a coaching video you're going to
do a demonstration video you're going to
do a one-on-one with a client video
you're going to do a reaction video
you're going to do a how-to video you're
going to do a
video from uh the stage you're gonna do
a big zoom call video like you're
playing with different ideas
so that you can start to see which ones
are working out
if you're up if you're starting to work
towards a content calendar
and you're moving from the once a week
to three to seven
don't do the same kind of video
on repeat
don't just stick to one format start to
play with different types different
content styles that feel
right for you
um for example i don't do reaction
videos
um i find a lot of the reaction videos
are are kind of negative i was like i
can't believe you just said that oh my
god what an idiot like i don't like
putting that energy out so i don't i
don't i don't like reaction videos
there's no reaction videos the only
reaction video i've ever done is me
reacting to my first video and i watched
it back and was mostly embarrassed and
[Laughter]
laughing at myself for how bad it was um
but for some of you maybe that's maybe
that is what would work super well um so
it's got to be it's got to feel right
it's got to be authentic but if you're
if you're getting to multiple times a
week make sure that you're having
different kinds of series you can start
seeing the data and seeing what's
working what's not
this is kind of a messy graph so i'm
going to explain it this is what i go
through with my team
every month
and this is this is some old data but i
pulled it up just to show you as an
example
this we use for every series on the
channel so i just pulled three out for
you guys to look at this is a top 10
series this is my top 50 series and this
is the entspresso which is a morning
series so this is us doing you know top
10 and oprah winfrey top 50 oprah
winfrey and espresso is more me talking
so it'd be
uh
a clip and then i'm talking about it
and then this goes on so we have each
color is a different channel so these
are just two channels and then there's a
green channel and then red and orange
and this is some giant sheet that i
didn't want to overwhelm you guys with
but what this basically looks at and um
ivan on my team he he pulls this
together for me once a month and we have
a call once a month to go over it is
we're looking at watch time
for the past month of videos and then
how many subscribers we gain per video
so what these two numbers mean is
if we were making our data uh what month
is it now we're in may okay so for june
when we have our meeting this number is
going to reflect how well how many watch
hours did we get
per video on average in this series
for two months back so the videos that
launched in april
one month of data being collected
and then
we talked about it in june
the reason why we do it like that is
uh
a channel that like mine has been around
for so long
a lot of the data a top 10 video from
2016 isn't relevant anymore to what's
happening right now
so i care about the new videos that are
coming up and how well they've done in
their first four to six weeks
so
the april videos
are contained
so there might be let's say there's 10
april videos in the top 10 series so
those 10 videos that launched in april
and if you guys have questions pop it in
the chat because this this part might be
a little confusing so i'm happy to
answer and go deeper on it but if we
release 10 top 10 videos in april
in june we'd then go back and look at
all the data
and say okay our top 10 videos got us on
average
389 000
watch hours and each video got us on
average 79 new subscribers between
launch date
and june
between april and june now these will go
on to continue to do super well but
we're tracking what happened in the
first four to six weeks of each video uh
so
what this helps us do
is start to analyze okay which series do
we keep going with
and which series do we cut
so
you know we uh we we did all these top
tens and i wanted to show this this this
data is probably 2017
2016 data um but we've kept this going
you know if i look show you my recent
ones and show that the newer stuff
this is where we did our first top 50 to
say hey what if we launch a new series
top 50.
let's just go super long on a video
so you can see our top 10s we're doing
122 000 watch hours and 16 subscribers
per video in that month we did a top 50
and look at the jump it went from it
went to 600 000
watch hours and 61 subscribers per video
the next month did super well the next
month didn't do so well we lost
subscribers
and only 128 000 watch hours so we're
constantly comparing these numbers and
you can look at it across series so if
we look at it this month here
you can see okay so the top ten
got got six figures watch time 17
subscribers
top 50 crushed it on both and the
espresso got 51 000 but half the watch
hours of this but double the subscribers
and so we're constantly playing with the
series to see which ones are doing well
then inside each one you can dive in to
see well which which video did well for
us inside here
you know so if these are 10 videos which
of them
did super well and which ones
didn't to give us more information but
this for you could be you know coaching
series this could be again all the
different options direct to camera
reaction etc and you start to pay
attention to
how many watch hours that i get from
these videos and how many subscribers
did i gain from these videos if you
wanted to add the third column of
revenue you could too
revenue is typically more topic driven
though
than series driven
um but if that's really really important
to you we don't track revenue as a as
the main metric for our youtube videos
um we care mostly about growth so
drew's got his hand up what where what
do you got drew so i'm just trying to
make sure i understand so each row
represents a single month
of that series having
been released yes yes yeah so this would
be june july august september you know
october and so on
so when collecting that data so i'm
assuming this is like on one
page and then on another page you have
each individual video the total
cumulative
and then that number just simply
reflects the sum of all of the videos
that were released that month
yeah so if again if this was june it'd
be the sum of all the videos
from
april that were released
and then divided by how many videos are
released so this is an average
this is per video oh oh okay okay yeah
because we'll do
you know we'll end up doing 22 top tens
in a month but only one top 50 as an
example
so to add them all up it doesn't make
sense you have to then give me on a per
video basis i don't think you have to go
this deep
even just i i'm obsessed with this stuff
so i've shown this to other
big youtubers like nobody tracks it
as detailed as you guys do
so you don't have to go to this level
i'm just showing you the idea is i want
you to start thinking about it on a
series level so we looked at channel
which is great but that's
to ashley's question but how do we make
strategic decisions that's hard when
you're just looking at total views and
total revenue um total subscribers etc
once you get to a series by series level
it starts to educate us to say hey these
ones are doing better than others so if
i look at this line and just a one-off
month we'll usually do it for at least
three months to see
a one-off month isn't enough
typically
so
but this month like the top 50 looks
like a
runaway winner and the next month is
also looking doing really well on the
watch hours not as well on the
subscribers compared and the next month
whatever we did here
sucked right we lost 21 subscribers so i
don't know who we profiled
or what that video was now again all
these videos will still end up winning
long term
this is first four to six weeks
and why four to six weeks is because
that's usually how long it takes for
suggested
to start to kick in
you might have a crazy runaway winner
that suggests it starts to pop
you know within the first week but for
the most part for most videos
you give that four to six week window
usually after 30-day mark you start to
see suggested views go up if the video
is going to do well
if you still don't see any suggested
views after 30 or 60 days that video is
probably dead
so it could be worth doing a redo on the
thumbnail title or just the video you
know itself wasn't very good
so this is how every month every month
since 2015
uh i've met with my guy ivan and we go
over this and we make decisions
afterwards from this and this sheet this
is only three columns this sheet is
maybe 20 columns long for all of our
series
and we'll just dive into each one and
say okay okay um this one this one's not
looking so good what do we need to do to
fix it
and the goal is always to try to pull
out
the
always have one test series that we're
trying to beat
the rest of our content to make it back
in
so if you're if you're making three
videos a week as an example you have
your two that you know are consistent
winners and then you have your one
that's a test
so maybe you're trying a book review or
maybe you're trying a role play or maybe
you're trying uh a coaching call you're
trying something
for four weeks
to just to see how well are we doing and
you're always trying to beat the winner
if you want to see this full video as
well as train live with me twice a month
to blow up your brand join the brand
linux training program there's a link to
join right there next to me continue to
believe i'll see you there